[Music]
[Laughter]
do you believe in the promise proclaimed
in the declaration of independence do
you believe that all of us are created
equal and that we have a natural right
to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and you also believe that we
should guarantee those rights to all
americans
of course you do
so let's think about what that means
on january 11 1944 president franklin d
roosevelt fdr delivered his 11th state
of the union message to congress
the united states was in the middle of
its biggest and most consequential war
pitted against nazi germany and imperial
japan but roosevelt didn't just talk
about winning the war he also spoke of
what americans needed to do to win the
peace to come
in a speech to congress that day he
called for a new bill of rights an
economic bill of rights
in the 1930s roosevelt and the american
people had fought the great depression
the worst economic and social
catastrophe in u.s history
rallying to the president's new deal
they not only had revived the economy
they had also subjected business and
finance to public supervision and
regulation empowered the federal
government to address the needs of
working people mobilize and organize
labor unions and civil rights groups
established a social security system
expanded and upgraded the nation's
public infrastructure improved the
environment and cultivated and promoted
the arts
in 1941 however americans confronted a
new crisis the second world war
but here too they went all out
in fact they not only did all they could
to fight fascism overseas but also
fought for democracy at home by
dramatically expanding the labor and
civil rights movements and by early 1944
there was good cause to believe both
that victory might soon be at hand and
that further progressive action was
possible
at the outset of the state of the union
speech roosevelt urged americans to
sustain the war effort but he also now
looked ahead
confident that americans who had
achieved so much wanted to not only
revive the new deal but in every way
expand upon it opinion polls conducted
in 1943 indicated for example that 83 of
americans wanted a guarantee of health
care for all 73 supported launching new
public works programs and 79 wanted a
federal jobs guarantee though he was too
sick to appear in person before congress
to deliver the speech roosevelt went on
radio and delivered a spirited address
and after reviewing the continuing war
effort he turned to the question of the
post-war peace effort in the united
states
this republic he said had its beginning
and grew to its present strength under
the protection of certain inalienable
rights they were our rights to life and
liberty
as our nation has grown in size and
stature however as our industrial
economy expanded these political rights
proved inadequate to assure us equality
in the pursuit of happiness the words
that followed are among the most radical
in presidential history
we have come fdr contended to a clear
realization of the fact
that true
individual freedom cannot exist without
economic security and independence
necesitous men are not free men
what he then proposed would be seen as
far left today though as he reminded his
fellow americans it was not a
repudiation of the promises enshrined in
the declaration and the bill of rights
but a continuation and realization of
them
indeed only with economic rights could
political rights be made real
as roosevelt said
in our day
certain economic truths have become
accepted as self-evident
a second bill of rights
under which a new basis of security and
prosperity
can be established for all
regardless of station or race or creed
the rights roosevelt was proposing a
right to a home to health care to earn
enough money to live comfortably a
guaranteed job would be called socialism
or even communism by today's
conservatives but whatever they might be
labeled they were rooted as fdr made
clear in america's promise of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
empowered by the aspirations of those
who had fought the depression and were
now fighting fascism roosevelt was
projecting a path to a better
brighter happier and healthier future
all of these rights he said spell
security and after this war is won we
must be prepared to move forward in the
implementation of these rights to new
goals of human happiness and well-being
but fdr knew all too well that there
were those who had fiercely opposed them
as they always had and he warned his
fellow citizens against what he called
the grave dangers of rightist reaction
what roosevelt laid out in his state of
the union was something simple
but radical it was that history wasn't
something to be left in the past but to
be constantly renewed
and remade
new times demand new freedoms just a few
years earlier his solicitor general
robert h jackson a future supreme court
justice told the members of the national
lawyers guild we too
are founders
we too are makers of a nation
we too are called upon to write to
defend and to make live new bills of
right at a demonstration in new york
city 1.4 million people showed up to
hear senator robert wagner
enthusiastically defend the call for a
second bill of rights labor and civil
rights groups actively campaigned for it
and in the presidential election later
that year roosevelt won a fourth term as
president with a resounding
432 electoral votes
roosevelt would not live to achieve his
dream at his fourth and final
inauguration in 1945 he appeared sick
and frail
while he was getting his portrait
painted just a few months later in warm
springs georgia he put his hand over his
forehead slumped over and died
the second bill of rights was never
realized the forces of righteous
reaction that fdr had warned of were too
powerful
corporate executives and conservatives
soon took to fermenting cold war fears
and purging public life of leftists not
only to block the hope for revival and
expansion of the new deal but also to
crush the very idea and memory of
roosevelt's proposed economic bill of
rights
that doesn't mean of course that his
vision has to remain shrouded and
forgotten what fdr promised though still
radical remains deeply possible if we
have the will to recover it and to
advance it
we too
can be founders we too can be makers of
a nation
we too are called upon to write
to defend to make live
new bills of rights
i'm harvey k professor emeritus of
democracy and justice at the university
of wisconsin green bay for the gravel
institute
[Music]
you